wow what episode are we on now
169. welcome back to the corridor
cast record cast my brain I'm gonna be
honest my brain is completely fried
from Houdini
I we've been working on satisfying
renders up in here for the past few days
now and I've been deep diving into more
flip fluid stuff inside of Houdini for
those of you who don't know that's
basically I mean your fluid simulations
right and I'm working on a small scale
and that means that it doesn't work very
well at least not for me so my head is
completely kaput
um but on the topic of Houdini the
perfect timing Urban verdesco's in the
house oh a fantastic Houdini artist
personal friend a friend of the channel
Here and Now First Time guest on the
podcast welcome aboard buddy thank you
it's is it this is the highlight of my
career everything from this point
forward it's downhill yeah yeah all
downhill from here that's how it feels
like yeah I peaked I mean maybe you
could tell us a bit about yourself like
yeah your background what you do
currently
well when I was a baby oh I love that
yeah let's start right there actually
can we predate that too tell them about
your family your parents yeah
no I dude I don't know I want I always
wanted to be a film director that was
the goal I feel like a lot of people
they start with I want to be in films
yeah and then like right after high
school they were like oh you need to go
to college for film directing I was like
no no I'll do my own Studio that feels
like a better way to learn oh wow it's
Brave so I did that for like seven eight
years wow and we did you know music
videos commercials stuff like that
but then clients they usually they they
wanted more and more Motion Graphics in
their in the in the you know just like
oh can you add a title at the end or at
the beginning and I started learning
after effects in Cinema 4D and then 3ds
Max and I dabbled with fume effects and
then finally I found Houdini ah which
was the biggest pain it still is the
biggest thing yeah it hurts so much and
you know oh yeah yeah I'm I'm much
earlier I mean how many years ago was
this like how many years into Houdini
are you now
like seven or eight oh yeah yeah nice it
feels like I'm at the beginning oh I so
it never changes how about you Jordan
how many years I'm three years in now
wow so I'm I still feel like having an
absolute infant yeah yeah I still feel
diapered up and it's crazy to think that
yeah even after eight years you still
feel like you're in the very beginning
no it's never never ends it's it's one
of those things like Houdini is a
software is by far the most impressive
software I've ever used yeah it's so
rich and deep and detailed and you have
I mean I almost equate it to being like
an information machine more than
anything else where you can have access
to any piece of information you want and
you can use it in whatever way you want
it is if you're interested in like hyper
flexible control from the the highest
possible level Houdini's for you and my
brain doesn't really work like that my I
don't have like
you know the the physician's brain or
like the the physicist rather you know
the kind of brain that handles but you
do you kind of have to because you are
using Houdini so your brain is a bit
maybe I'm like just in the doorway but
yeah it doesn't feel like it it feels
like I'm constantly hitting my head
against the wall yeah like Houdini's a
little bit like with that access to all
the information and stuff like you can
get the actual like specific position of
like one single vertice it's a little
bit like the original like rudimentary
3D modeling programs yeah yeah so you
can just take that information and do
everything yeah yeah pretty much that's
what's insane yeah yeah and get a
beautiful visual representation rather
than just being like render
wait for 10 days and then you get to see
a like low poly hand yes yeah it's the
flow of information it's like it's so
beautiful to wear like literally
anything you can think of doing
it's attainable you know to a certain
degree
um obviously the more like used to it
you are the better you can you can do I
mean urban like your explosion stuff
yeah is Top Notch you know like we we
did me and Nico did a video on the crew
Channel not too long ago diving into
explosions and we actually used some of
Urban's work and and spoke with Urban
about that because you know you're
you're at the highest levels of this
thing as far as explosions I kind of
niched down the explosions guy yeah yeah
that's what like I love doing explosions
yeah it's kind of like the coolest
simulation yeah we're talking cool this
is the wrong way to learn Houdini by the
way is to start doing explosions yeah
that's exactly what I did like how did
you start with Houdini simulations and
stuff yeah my first foray into Houdini
was actually during the pandemic yeah I
had all day every day because all the
work dried up and I was like well I mean
if there were ever a time to take the
biggest leap ever Now's the Time and
I've been procrastinating for years
point and so I just set aside I
basically built like a Pomodoro study
pattern that would would have me
studying for eight to ten hours a day
and I just go until my brain literally
hurt and then I'd go take a breather
yeah get the courage back and tackle it
again yeah and I did that over and over
and over until eventually I had my first
breakthrough and for those of you who
have done Houdini or have even studied
any program you'll know what I'm talking
about where you have that click and it's
like that's it's almost like a time
trial in a game and you get through the
ring that adds more time to it yeah
those are the clicks to me those keep
you going and it's like oh I chased
those once you're able to like actually
just be flowing in a program or not
you're not just like hitting yourself
and be done when you come back yeah like
I've had a couple moments like that and
those are my little speed boosts but
yeah I started um on a project basis I
started with a Steven nipping tutorials
he's the best he's amazing he's such a
good teacher yeah CG circuit I believe
is where you can find his stuff and and
it's like you know a pig that is
vomiting water yeah like these these
exercises that are introducing you to
the fundamental that's right the the
flip side the rigid body destruction
side the Pyro side and by just tackling
those projects individually I started to
come to appreciate that these are all
connected under the hood and it's all
just information and it completely
changed the way that I saw and worked
with visual effects
um and again even though I'm only three
years in I still feel like fundamentally
it changed me as an artist yeah um and
so eight years in I imagine I mean did
you start the same way or you started
with with pyro specifically pyro I went
into pyro it was and I was like I know
Houdini yeah and I didn't know anything
yeah I only knew how the thing is
even with explosions you need to set up
your emitters and the way you do like
complex emitters you need to know all
the other areas of Houdini so if you
don't know Houdini well
your Pyro's gonna suck even though if
you know how to do simulations like you
cannot just do one without the other
yeah but I went straight into explosions
and I was like something's missing I
need to learn the whole other part of
Houdini and then that took like a few
years yeah and yeah I want like when
you're working in a studio you kind of
have to know everything yeah and that is
tough can be very difficult because and
Houdini is changing all the time yeah
like they're introducing your tools new
this and that and then sometimes you're
doing magical effects and then you're
doing explosions and then you're doing
destruction and it it can burn you out
so I was like no no I just want to do
explosions from now on because I don't
want to like focus on one area and
become very good at it like specialize
in explosions
and then I met Matthew puchala who did
yeah like he did his uh he did Axiom
like act so me and Matthew we work
together now on uh a company called
Theory accelerated and the company is
making software and the first software
that uh Matthew developed was Axiom yeah
I mean I've seen Jordan using it yeah
insane like like game changing software
it's like it's amazing yeah for those of
you who don't know what Axiom is it's
essentially this this third-party pyro
solver uh that Matt developed I
genuinely don't know how well he did it
absolutely yeah yeah maybe one day but
coded this thing that is so fast in
solving pyro and it's so beautiful like
it I hated pyro truly like as someone
who's very inexperienced in it I didn't
like it it took forever it felt clunky
and I wasn't sure how to navigate it and
Axiom just expedited the process like
you iterate through uh through like
results so much faster to where it I've
said it before but it brings the
Artistry back to the process where
you're not waiting and watching a
loading screen for 10 minutes to see if
the button you changed by one iteration
is going to make a huge difference
you're watching it happen yeah and
that's crucial so crucial dude I had
like we had I had instances where I had
to wait you know three four hours for an
explosion yeah and then the deadline is
coming up and you're like you you do the
high-res and then it it's not what you
want it to be yeah well now I have to
wait another four hours but I don't know
if it's going to be good
just rolling the dice oh there's nothing
more stressful so this is where if you
if your emitter is very good yeah you
will shape your the emitter will shape
your explosion when you say emitter what
do you mean it's like
like with real explosions you have like
gas or like uh gunpowder and stuff like
that that's your emitter you know you
you have to you ignite it yeah and
that's gonna push everything up so in CG
you have to do the same thing you have
to look at it as if it was a real thing
and do your emitter properly like for
instance like if you have an explosion
like
underground like like a dust explosion
it would lift up the ground yeah and
then the debris and dust would fly up
and it would just freaking all the
particles
that will make the the explosion right
yeah you have to simulate that in
Houdini first before you do the Sim yeah
yeah you're almost thinking I mean
literally at the end of the day in
Houdini for the most part you're trying
to recreate yeah real life real life
yeah so taking into account genuine
sources of explosions of what they do
and how they operate is integral to
creating something that's realistic so
that's going to shape it so if you
that's why I said before you have to
know other aspects of food you need to
do good explosions let's say for me I
use I usually use
either flip
for my emitters or grains so grains will
imitate that ground like dust and mud
kind of particles it's and that will
shape your explosion a bit so with
grains that's done in the Vellum system
correct and the way that Vellum works is
Vellum is taking into account the
particle relationships yeah so as it
explodes it's like clinging to its
neighbors and clumping in certain ways
you can design all of that but by
simulating that first you have the
clumpy soil or whatever it is it's
exploding versus what you said flip
which would operate more like gasoline
or just spray or just particles yeah
shooting out and so yeah different
approaches to different explosions
different explosions yeah so you get
different results yeah because in
Hollywood they usually use the gas
explosion so they would launch a lot of
fuel up in the air and then they would
ignite it yeah so again yeah the chase
really cool people kind of I mean I
guess they still look cool yeah
but because they are I think they're
overusing them a bit so everybody knows
Ah that's a fake Hollywood explosion
yeah but it's still fun yeah still
something blowing up also yeah yeah do
you have a uh this is always a hard
question but do you have a favorite like
explosion you've done like you're you're
like this is my baby this is like I
would show someone first if I'm like
this is the best thing I've ever yeah so
we did one I did one it was for a rebel
way Workshop cool it was a big like
nuclear explosion
and I was watching so uh the reference
was
um the explosion from Star Wars
Rogue one yeah yeah
uh Miguel did that explosion he's like
like he's my hero gosh like he's the
best the effects artist ever nuts so
that was my reference but then I I
I all I also always watch anime for
explosions anime has the best timing
Yeah man so then I can start combining
like real explosions plus anime and you
just get the best thing yeah you capture
the the sense of energy because the it's
like about the energy yeah yeah it's
it's I mean we were talking earlier at
lunch and you were saying that you know
a friend of yours who is an animator
first and foremost has some of the best
work in Houdini because they understand
the flow they understand motion yeah and
like what is satisfying and that's
that's an aspect that I've never taken
into account yeah yeah um is how that
factors in you know you could do
something simply but if it has
attractive motion all of a sudden it
elevates the entire thing so much more
yeah when we were working on uh anime
rock paper scissors like there's that
big finale shot and that was just like
we're like okay what makes an anime
explosion so good and it's because
there's like four frames yeah before it
goes off where you're just like it's
just gonna go black you're gonna see a
white outline of people there's gonna be
it's like
yeah it's so good so it's like it's
really cool that you're like taking
those concepts of like traditional anime
and then applying it to like these
amazing photo realistic like Houdini
simulations and it's just it I I saw
that simulation you did the one you say
is your favorite like Jordan showed to
me I was like that might be the best
like it is so cool because yeah like
you know eventually like a simulation it
just you'll be like that just looks
photo real but because yours had that
yeah like
um influence of the anime like action
style to it it was like that just has
such a good feel to it yeah where it's a
nice pop yeah it doesn't just have that
like you know Hollywood gas explosion it
was like okay there's something out
there it's directed it's not just like
uh let's blow it up see what happens
exactly yeah it was really cool yeah you
need to Art direct yeah even that's why
I love explosions like a lot of people
are like ah they're so boring to do like
my uh supervisor back at access he was
like why do you love explosion so much
like nobody wants to do that no no no
this is the best this is all I want to
do yeah right so I that's when I was
like no I this is like my my calling or
the explosions and I would ask him I can
you know do even more of that yeah yeah
I mean it's so much faster I mean do you
do you still feel the same way about
explosions today like you do you still
love them the same way you did are you
itching to do other things no no I love
it I'm just doing a GDC talk
specifically about accident explosions
and I'll show how to do some of the
emitters and talk about the logic behind
it how to shape explosions so that's
going to be it's next week that's
awesome yeah that's very pretty cool
yeah oh go ahead you go ahead oh I was
gonna say there's like there's so much
in Houdini to do because that's the
thing is like I'm curious because Fenner
you're you're coming from a traditional
pipeline as well yeah where you focused
on compositing yeah namely and you
focused on explosions inside of Houdini
yeah the idea of generalism like as an
art form is that sustainable if you're
trying to climb the more traditional
pipeline route I think my opinion on it
is
specialize in one thing like my kind of
industry path was like cool I'm going to
start as a junior compositor work your
way up to like a mid then a senior then
a lead then a comp supervisor yeah once
you've hit that you've kind of maxed out
that yep and ideally by that point
you've been putting in enough work
outside of your standard you know
working Studio environment to bring up
all your other skills as well or you're
at least
you know in the room enough to be like
okay I understand what the effects team
is doing I understand what the like
animation team's doing
and then you can kind of graduate to
that bfx supervisor level where you're
like yeah okay even if I can't directly
jump into Houdini I at least need to be
able to talk to my effects lead yeah and
be like hey this is what we need can you
do it in the style yeah talk to your
animation lead and be like we need this
this and this so that's where being a
generalist I think is like if you do
want to be in that traditional pipeline
can be really helpful once you've reach
that point
um that served me really well in my
career but if I had just started from
day one being like I'm gonna be the best
at everything you will be the best at
nothing yeah yeah Jack of all trades
master of nothing exactly yeah I
remember when I was teaching I had a
student that was like
um really awesome kid and he was like
yeah I want to I want to specialize in
being a generalist I'm like that doesn't
make any sense yeah
yeah yeah yeah and I eventually I was
like he's like well I really love
simulation stuff I'm like then
specializing me like yeah just do that
yeah and because he was like I want to
do this crazy animation and then this
and then and then and then and then I'm
like that's so much time yeah and all of
your work will suffer because you're
spreading out your time on this like
Grand scale rather than taking your time
and just hyper focusing on something
like explosions yeah like it's it's the
Skyrim skill tree yeah is this guy I'm
skull tree and I what I loved about
Skyrim is it is you only level up the
things you're doing it's the same so
that's how that's how I view life yeah
it's like a game and I'm just leveling
up like explosions 100. yeah 100 and
then but honestly like when I was
working at access Studios like they even
us like the FX artists we had to do
pre-comps so we all needed to learn how
to composite yeah and I feel like you
cannot be a good uh like VFX Houdini
without knowing how to comp yeah because
then how because you don't know what the
other guy will need yeah what aovs to
give them exactly though it's like yeah
the pass is how it's going to look like
so we did pre-comps usually like huge
comps yeah like they were huge uh and
once you I feel like if you if you first
learn how to composite you're gonna have
a better time doing if you then want to
specialize in Houdini or whatever yeah
you're gonna have a better time because
you're gonna know the yeah Foundation
like the fundamental things yeah the
school I taught it like it was very much
you could go specialize in kind of any
field in VFX but I would always say like
to my students I'm like you don't have
to become a compositor but just keep
attending this class yeah because you're
going to use compositing on every single
piece of yourself even if you're an
animation student because I would show a
comparison I was like okay here's one
reel from an animation student where
it's a grayscale rig and here's another
one and this other student had done this
amazing beautifully composited shot that
had really nice depth of field it looked
so like just filmic and beautiful and I
was like guess who got hired first
because it just shows you it's like you
have an understanding of yeah art
Direction and that's what it is an
explosion you understand
Cinema you understand what looks good
you understand when you look at
something even if you don't understand
it you're like I know how to make
someone get that feeling of I like that
yeah you don't know why yeah like but I
like it yep yeah we're we're uh in the
in the process of looking for like a new
place to live me and my fiance right now
and as we're looking at these places
like some have decorated the space and
some have not yeah and the places that
have not naturally it's harder to
Envision what is supposed to be there
and compositing is very similar where
it's like fill in the gaps for the
people who can't like imagine it and
your work will stand out so much more
than just like the Bare Bones you know
like that grayscale animation like set
deck yeah freaking lay it down and fill
in the blanks for them yeah and nothing
can like save or kill a shot more than
compositing because you could get the
most incredible like Houdini Sim yeah
and then a compositor that doesn't know
what they're doing could just ruin that
that's what was crazy like we were
looking at the Rogue one explosion I was
just thinking up yeah it's Bonkers it's
amazing I showed you that right you
showed it I was like dude look at this I
couldn't believe like you strip away the
compositing and it's still a very sexy
Sam yeah but it looks like it looks like
a Sim yeah and then you add the
compositing element you're like oh this
just wrapped the baby up with a bow and
I was actually ignorant to the power of
compositing until you started working
here and I gotta like see what you were
doing and you got to speak that truth
into me because you know I felt like my
stuff elevated dramatically with like
the tips you were giving me yeah you
know like we did uh we did a Christmas
render challenge yeah and I had my
little elves pulling on Santa
I was pulling on Santa and out of
Houdini it was it was cute but it was
like it's pretty blah yeah and then man
when you add that that thing let's be
real you just have to ask hello
yeah everything between
the event and the camera yeah yeah in
the curriculum I built out my second
last class was titled polishing the turd
yeah because I would literally give the
class I'm like here's the worst render
you could possibly get that you might
end up getting at a studio yeah you have
to make this shot look good that's your
assignment for the week yeah like by any
means necessary and it was really cool
because some students would go in and be
like I'm just gonna rebuild whole
portions of the shot and then comp it
all together yeah and then some would
just be like I graded it yeah like it
just depends but there's so much you can
do to change it and polish it throw
stuff out of focus and hide it oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah you would be surprised
what do you get in like a real
production environment like the passes
sometimes are horrible yeah yeah then
what compositors like do to fix it yes
you would be
I've seen some stuff yeah and this is on
like the highest level stuff too right
yeah yeah high level stuff and you're
you're like this is there's no way this
is gonna work and then one week later a
good compositor would take it it would
be released and you're like what this is
not how it looked like a week ago like
they completely saved the show yeah well
a huge part of it is time constraints
too it's like where
you know eventually it's just like okay
if you are waiting four hours for each
simulation it's like this is it this is
done we we can't you know it's like we
can't run it again yeah I'm getting a
second-hand anxiety just from hearing
that yeah like just watching the clock
Tech is
uh you know is the worst I think it's
the worst feeling in visual effects yeah
when you're the time is running out you
just have to watch a loading bar and
you're not sure what's on the other side
of it yeah there's nothing that's worse
usually compositors end up doing the
most overtime because you're the last
step where it's like FX artist and the
compositor exactly yeah we are at the
end yeah it's just like guys we gotta
make it better and then it's like yeah
yeah it's so bad because it was funny
when I was at access I I was also doing
the layout yeah because I used to be a
cinematographer and then every now and
then I was like critiquing some cameras
and they're like oh do you wanna you
wanna do layout as well it's like yeah
sure I'll do layout and then effect as
well so I was at the beginning of the
project and at the end yeah which is
nice yeah and the beginning was always
chill yeah I talked with the directors
you would be like you would work on the
storyboards with the editors yeah and it
would be super chill and then when you
start doing effects and calm it's just
like go go go no yeah everything else
for for the people out there who don't
know like the traditional pipeline or
the flow I guess of of how it handles in
post like what what is the typical
pass-through for like yeah for all the
stages of of an effect shot effect shot
or just like in general like I'd say in
general or like I guess for cinematics
or movies it's the same pipeline yeah
pretty much yeah yeah well you start
with the storyboards and then you put
the storyboards in the edit and then you
shuffle them around just with the
storyboards you you kind of get a feel
of how the scenes are gonna flow
and then you do first pass previous
which is just like characters like yeah
and some people work only in previous oh
I did previous and then layout and then
polish layout and then we would go on
mocap shoots and then we would do first
pass animation
and then you put that in the edit again
and like the edit and layout and
animation like they're always working
like side by side
and then some stuff gets approved it
gets handed out over to effects and then
the effects will do stuff and then the
animation will change and the effects
people would freak out yeah yeah
and then
yeah and then compositing would kind of
start happening as soon as possible yeah
as soon as you get that first effects
render yeah because yeah you you don't
usually you would pick a shot it like we
called it a vertical slice I'm not sure
what you guys call it a Veta yeah
vertical size yeah there you go anything
like that hero shot hero shot you you
get that to a good point so everybody's
like okay this is gonna work yeah you
know you need to show it to your to the
clients or the director yeah get their
confidence up that you know we know what
we're doing yeah and then yeah you just
polish it and
and we had a situation where the client
decided to
change the characters oh like who's
gonna die at the end like we're late
into the like two weeks before the
deadline and how and how long had you
been working with the original character
oh yeah like for like three or four
months no and then yeah they switched
who's gonna die at the end I was like no
no no no no no way yeah and I was like
no no it's fine but we need more time
they're like no no no there's no more
time because
um well they have they had a deadline
yeah
and then I was like well it's not
happening and we well it happened we
fixed it but it was bad you know yeah
you can't like stuff like that
yeah that's why that's intense that's
why people burn out yeah a lot of times
and
yeah it's not
just there's nothing you can do about it
just happens yeah yeah VFX is uh you
know I've never had a job more where
someone says no we can't do that and
then it gets done
[Laughter]
it's like the standard language response
it's like no no no that's every comedy
ever written where they're like I'm
never gonna do that yeah
but in real life yeah yeah yeah the
problem is we are so passionate we would
do it anyway yeah and then everybody
works over time everybody works over the
weekends yeah I get it but at a certain
point
you get a bit tired of that but we still
do it I guess I don't know yeah like you
said you need to learn to love the
process otherwise it it's just pain all
the time yeah you love the process if
you love a bit of that pain you're gonna
be fine yeah yeah because the the I mean
I've said it before but there never is
an end to the journey right like like in
Houdini alone let alone all the other
projects all the other techniques all
the other filmmaking tricks you can pick
up you're never gonna finish you're
always going to be learning and so
learning to enjoy each you know speed
boost on the time trial every moment of
success you know every frustration that
you break through like those are the
rewards yeah and if you can train your
brain to appreciate those moments and
not pursuing the feeling of finishing a
project oh we did it it's done like uh
the my my brain is happy if you can
instead break it down to even smaller
segments and just appreciate all this
moment this one thing like the flip
stuff we again my brain broke today a
little bit at the beginning of this you
can kind of tell but uh you know my
brain was breaking doing that stuff but
at the very end of it I'm going okay but
there are things that I can pull from
this that made today a success and that
made today really exciting to me yeah
and it's that it's the training of just
appreciating the journey but on the
other side of that you're right it can
be taken advantage of right by the
clients who come in and say this needs
to be done now this needs to be done
here and you're so passionate about it
and I know we say it a lot on this
channel but obviously a lot the maybe
all but a vast majority of the bad
visual effects that we see are a result
of these timeline issues probably yeah
it's not it's very rarely an Artistry
issue it's just all these changes that
we don't see
and all of it falling on the last leg of
this production which is the visual
effects Department you know like
these timelines are insane and the asks
are insane and the artists push so hard
and yeah it's like I've always regretted
not diving into the conventional
pipeline because you know you guys have
worked on such cool stuff and I just I
look at myself and I'm like I would love
to say that I worked but uh or like you
know worked on you know with you know
Riot and all these cool things you guys
have done but at the same time I hear
these stories and I'm like okay maybe I
saved myself a few years yeah yeah you
know what I mean from the from the line
that's good yeah it's good and it's bad
I mean like you kind of have to do it
and then you're like no no I feel like
what you guys do here at Corridor that's
what I would love to do now after I went
through everything with like a
traditional pipeline The Gauntlet yeah
yeah yeah it's a it is interesting on
that like note too it's like I don't
know if you watch the Oscars at all but
just the it is that you know mentality
in the film industry where it's like the
effects is like the last step where
you're just like ah it's okay and like
yeah I don't know if you saw like Eric
is it Saint on cindine who was on the
show incredible like WETA Avatar they
won the Oscar yeah best VFX with the
only person that night that got ushered
off the stage they got cut off yeah it's
like yeah they did no way just the beach
was going a little too long it's like
they were the ones that they cut it off
and I'm like that's like
it just keeps happening and it's like
it's the one kind of filmmaking aspect
that isn't unionized and it's just all
this stuff but it's like so much wrong
with it and people also take it well
like with uh was it um top gun Maverick
yeah they were like oh it was actually
all practical and then the visual
effects people were like no yeah yeah
but we're nominated for best visual
effects yeah exactly one of one of my
buddies uh Christian pack he's an
incredible artist and he was nominated
for a VES award for Top Gun and I was
joking with him oh my God I thought
there weren't any VFX in them yeah like
you know it's just it was they
frustrating it's like to not be able to
talk about your work because of this
like VFX being a dirty word in the
industry and all like these different
directors that are like yeah we shot
everything practically yeah like it's
like man
like you know I I love Christopher Nolan
he's one of my favorite directors but
he's very much one of those people that
is like we shoot everything practically
and I'm like
do you Interstellar bro yeah
yeah yeah fun fact Oppenheimer I'm sure
there's going to be some amazing Houdini
simulations in that they are doing
something like they are actually want to
see how they're going to do the nuke
right I'm sure apparently he's blown up
an actual nuke but no no way that's what
he's saying like that's what's out there
it's like because of this like we're
gonna blow everything up for real
probably gonna be a big explosion and
they're gonna put it in slow motion or
something exactly right it's like you'll
shoot it on a phantom camera and be like
look how big it is well I wonder like
there's the idea of the Union right like
ayatsi I think yeah is is I and I'm I'm
woefully ignorant to this I don't know
if you guys are any more like I I I'm
kind of tracking yeah that are happening
but I'm not exactly sure yeah because I
I remember like starting to look into
that before I started working here yeah
and I'm just I don't know why and there
may be really valid Reasons I'm just not
sure why why there isn't a union for
visual effects yet because I don't know
it feels like we need the protection
there's constantly abuses taking place
within the industry
like so much talent and so much ability
and it just feels like man what is
stopping us from banding together and
being more of like a cohesive unit here
I'm really not sure I think what it is
um
is because like there's been you know uh
Studios that have tried to unionize and
like I think especially around like
London and stuff is has been a huge part
of it and the studios just have so much
power to be like all right you're all
laid off because no one's unionized so
they can just do that and unfortunately
there is such a like it is such a
competitive industry that they're just
able to replace all those people and
because it's like whatever just throw
money at it we can completely flip this
team and that's obviously over over
simplifying the issue but it's like
it's kind of
yeah it's it's basically just the like
yeah that's fine try to unionize your
like which is awful like
um obviously very complex issues yeah I
know yeah I know it is yeah it's it is
weird that pretty much every other asset
of filmmaking is unionized like
so I just wonder if like maybe being
Global too has something to do with it
where it's like you know the teachers
union here it's like that's in person at
least it is again now yeah uh but that
that feels easier to control than like
artists who are in Canada and Australia
and India and New Zealand and America
and it gets it it becomes an interesting
thing too because you end up with issues
of Studios being so Global now and
people working remote
um
like it just becomes very interesting
where one studio will be like well this
country actually has these laws in place
so we have to abide by those or if
you're working remote it's like okay
which countries laws am I going by as
well and like
you know I signed a contract that says
this but technically that's illegal in
this country so it's a really again I
think that plays into it and it's like
it needs to be I mean it's called I was
about to say it needs to be a
unification that's what a union is it
really does need to be globally
every artist at every Studio yeah
together because as soon as one studio
is like no let's not do it guys it's
like
you know
I think
I do think it'll happen because I think
there has been this like Groundswell of
like you know every time
there's
someone getting cut off stage at the
Oscars it's like come on that like
and you're talking about for for a film
that is just visual effects yeah yeah
exactly it's up for Best Picture yeah
like that's the
yeah
well the whole picture is it yeah like
best picture it's all rendered yeah yeah
and it's wow yeah it's it's crazy man
there is a
yeah it's like this level of like yeah
it's the computer still do it yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think people don't know
about about it enough yeah have you guys
seen the light and Magic documentary yes
it's so incredible yeah you see they
they were kind of celebrating visual
effects in those documentaries yeah and
what you know you know the spaz Williams
yeah you know he did all the Jurassic
Park slash yeah yeah but he also didn't
get mentioned at the Oscars have you
guys seen the his documentary uh it's a
Jurassic Punk yeah have you seen it I
haven't seen it what yeah it's so good
yeah he he was super depressed like he
kind of pioneered all those workflows oh
yeah and then he didn't get the praise
or even they never mentioned him like on
the when they won the Oscar he was so
pissed like there's footage of him
watching the Oscars and they didn't
mention him and he was like you know
what the [__] yeah yeah what is
happening and then he got a bit
depressed and then I guess his attitude
attitude and everything uh I think they
fired him from ilm yeah which is why he
should have if there was ever such a
thing as tenure in visual effects yeah I
think he deserves it I think he's kind
of gone a little bit oh is he a Twitter
conspiracy kind of thing lately no it's
happening yeah I think he's a little bit
like conspiracy theorist kind of guy
like huh well he was he went to rehab
for alcohol Jesus but it was bad because
he like he did so much work and it was
funny because they told him not to do it
yeah yeah that's right they were they
were gonna do it with um stop motion
stop motion and he was like um yeah I
know a better way and then he kind of
went yeah you know the story is if I'm
not mistaken is uh Dennis you're in yeah
wanted to go the stop-motion route I
believe yeah yeah and he was taking the
producers of the film Jurassic Park on a
tour yeah and they played it on the
screen as the producer walked by and she
just happened to look over and go uh
what's that yeah yeah and then Dennis
had to take her over
and then once they saw it and Spielberg
saw it they're like we're done with
stop-motion we're moving for the poor
what's his name Phil Tippett yeah oh
poor guy because that was his thing yeah
it's yeah you have to kill something for
something else to be born exactly and
obviously we won't go into it because
Nico's not here but that leads into the
AI question right yeah yeah it's it's
the same it's the same thing that comes
up when these new tools come and then
there's all the questions about usage
and and how it's fair and why it's fair
if it's fair and you guys destroyed the
whole industry yeah man it just becomes
one of those things again so it's it's
interesting seeing that from far away
and then seeing this new Revolution take
place like uh chat GPT yeah the newest
version just came out lgbt4 I think
today oh a few days ago a few days ago
yeah what's new in that I you you were
mentioning that you you're more up to
date I played just a bit because I'm
here traveling I I had haven't had the
time but apparently you can upload
pictures you can upload videos you it's
gonna like you can just sketch something
like you can do a rough layout of our
website
upload it and you just say dude this is
the rough sketch just make it good write
all the stuff that a website needs yeah
oh my gosh it's just crazy it's gonna do
it for you what I was uh I was
explaining kind of all this AI stuff to
a friend of mine that doesn't really no
the VFX industry and all that and kind
of I think the take I've landed on is
that
people are very afraid that machines are
going to take people's jobs but I think
the fear should be yeah the people that
are learning to use these machines are
going to be the ones that that's your
job yeah it's a tool yeah it's the same
again light and Magic goes into it when
Photoshop it was the same thing it just
happened the people that refused to
learn that you become unfortunately your
skill set becomes Antiquated yeah and
it's like they're again it's a very
competitive industry they're going to be
10 people that are like hey I know how
to use Photoshop I could make that map
painting in a day and now it's like hey
I know how to use a journey I can make
that map painting in 10 seconds yeah and
I can do 50 500 iterations yeah exactly
just pick one and in in light imagine
they were saying that they took people
from stop motion yeah and from the from
the sfx Department I think and they
introduced them to visual effects and a
lot of them started learning those
things and became the pioneers of visual
effects yeah yeah and it's like this
this does feel like I know there's
Nuance to it obviously but this does
feel like the next wave of that where
yeah it's again yeah it's a tool how do
you use the tool yeah because at the end
of the day as much as like let's say um
a tool comes along in Ai and I'm sure it
will where they can handle the
simulation side well that's what that's
something I'm interested in yeah yeah
I'm very close in this industry to
simulations and I don't know exactly how
they would Implement AI for simulations
the way I would probably do it is you
would have ai Run a thousand
a million iterations yeah just doing
different simulations and then it would
kind of know
every outcome you know like Doctor
Strange yeah like I know all the
outcomes yeah and then you could like
feed in one feed some Source footage of
the kind of explosion I kind of like
feeded the footage and you like do this
and he's gonna know oh I know exactly
which iterations I I need to pick yeah
and like if that happens which is a very
real possibility because the people
developing this stuff are geniuses it's
getting just faster and faster I refuse
to be someone who who sits here and goes
I've poured so many years of my life
into learning this you're not allowed to
do that yeah because it I think in the
grand scheme of things if I take myself
out of the equation who am I to stop the
progress of this thing yeah if anything
I'm Gonna Get on Board and say hey I'm
really grateful that I have this well of
knowledge to what's going on under the
hood how can I use that to my advantage
while using the new tools available it
has to be that way and going back to
what we were talking about before the
art Direction side of it yeah it's you
know yeah because that if you just type
in prom a really good explosion it's not
gonna happen it's not gonna happen but
if you really you know craft that AI
generated thing and then you take it and
then you're working with that as an
element that's when it's gonna work
you're using that as like maybe it gets
to a point where it's giving you like an
effects cache and then it's like how are
you shaping that how are you doing
everything to that to make it work yeah
because
I think that's the thing too it's like
the deeper you dive into this Ai and
machine learning stuff you do realize
how much of it is just a tool and it's
incredible and it is industry changing
and people are going to lose their jobs
but
all of those people that are potentially
going to lose their jobs
uh I Feel Like a Villain saying this but
there is an onus to just learn the new
and up and coming things because new
jobs appear yeah when new tech appears
yeah and it's not a one-to-one maybe but
it's yeah it's at the same the same time
like sitting there and refusing isn't
going to benefit anybody and it's not
gonna stop anything that's just the
reality of it and so you will always
have people like let's say traditional
painters yeah they're gonna just paint
traditionally and that's fine yeah and
they they're going to be you know the
best at doing that uh let's say even
stop motion you still have stop-motion
animation yeah won the Oscar this year
there you go even though that was gosh
it wasn't that good oh my word yeah yeah
I was flow I watched it two nights ago
yeah yeah and I was floored and that's
like having this barrier to entry
lowered by stuff like Ai and machine
learning it does almost make the
traditional art form more valuable yeah
like I feel like people appreciated
Pinocchio more yeah because people are
sort of starting to understand it's like
oh my God yeah so much work I certainly
did yeah like you know I appreciate that
one a lot more than the Tom Hanks
Pinocchio because I'm like that's just
an animated thing yeah where this is
like handcrafted frame by frame housing
with traditional painting yeah same
thing I have so much more respect for
traditional painter now yeah I feel like
the industry like what I feel like
everything in life goes into like in a
yeah goes up and down you know you have
like big waves and you have like smaller
waves and then a big wave yeah and then
things are changing and you know nobody
wants stop motion for a while and then
stop motion comes back yeah and now
people are going to use AI they're gonna
make amazing things and then maybe
they're gonna go back to oh no let's do
this you know yeah with our own hands
because it's more valuable or like in
the I don't know like things are
changing yeah all the time well I'm even
inside of Houdini like yeah you know
make it make it a much much smaller
thing where it's hey I've spent all this
time learning the Pyro solver yeah and
then Axiom comes along yeah and it just
expedites everything so now this new
artist using axiom's moving way faster
than me yeah
I'll just I you know I'll I'll keep what
I've learned I'll hold on to that and I
can maybe be useful to some degree you
know but I'll jump onto the new thing
yeah and and that's the that is the art
of filmmaking that's always what's gonna
happen through your entire career is
gonna be new stuff that comes up all the
time yeah and it's like there is an art
to adaptability too that is a a key part
of being an artist is the ability to
adapt to the environment that's ever
changing and you know if you want to be
a part of the latest
you have to be a part of the latest you
know what I mean yeah yeah
um or you can you can do your own thing
and you can you know like you know
handcrafted wooden furniture like well
people would think incredibly valuable
yeah very beautiful very you know and
beautiful Niche yeah some people would
rather go to Ikea and get it for cheaper
faster made like Ikeas will exist in
every industry yeah
yeah yeah and it's yeah VFX
dude yeah so I don't know I it's just my
my personal opinion on it and yeah
obviously it's a very nuanced thing but
I think they're the only real question
with AI comes down to
um
uh you know utilizing the artist where
can we talked about this a bunch right
we don't need to go and do it again but
yeah yeah it's like how do we give
credit where credit's due or build our
own completely custom database that we
pull from because then it's all good
yeah like that really is the one caveat
of using other people's work yeah
ethically questionable at the moment but
as that stuff sort of becomes
regulated and smoothed out and yeah that
will be better because it definitely
right now it's like it can feel gross
you're like this is someone else's art
yeah and so that's where it's like
that's the only problem that I have with
it as well everything else is great and
yeah it's gonna be you know they're
gonna figure it out yeah a few lawsuits
later
yeah exactly I I thought it would be
really cool I mean I don't I guess I'm
talking to the people who develop this
stuff if there was any way
algorithmically to allocate a percentage
readout of what was used oh even if it's
like 0.01 you know this artist and this
image and you know six percent
compositionally dedicated to this credit
the original artists we get accredited
readouts that then you multiply against
the earnings of the object oh it has to
be and then you can distribute yeah you
know yeah that would be then all of a
sudden it becomes a tool that
everybody's into because you're getting
Spotify and you get 0.01 cents if your
image is used like honestly yeah I mean
it's not like that's something where if
you started to involve like blockchain
and that sort of thing that's a good
idea could become like financially
viable that's a good startup and what
you do as the artist you're like here
I'm giving you my data set yeah to that
company and they're like sweet well
we'll see when it's generated out of
mid-journey that it uses one percent of
your thing you get two dude and if
there's a transparent away blockchain
yeah then it becomes all of a sudden
this industry shaping thing I mean yeah
yeah we just there you go yeah
guys yeah with the first one's free
first and last one so yeah I mean I
don't know I don't know if it's viable
but anyone out there wants to you know
give that a shot shoot that'd be pretty
cool uh but yeah besides that obviously
I'm I'm out of my depth with with all of
AI stuff I'm I'm so happy in Houdini
right now and like just toiling away and
and trying to get better and better
because Houdini like it's not just
simulation stuff they have a whole new
kinfect suite of tools for character
animation and rigging and ragdolling and
partial ragdolling and
it like it's such a robust system on
every level you can even do compositing
you can even do compa yeah did you know
that yeah I don't know if it's any good
though is it any good
you may as well look use the tool for
the job.com
there's a reason you have nuke yeah I
think they're gonna make it better but
it's not their priority yeah yeah but
it's good to have though honestly yeah
like quick slap comps you put a few
passes together yeah yeah and now
they're they're introducing karma too
obviously as like a production ready
yeah renderer yeah yeah um I've had some
success with it so far yeah yeah do you
like it uh there's there's obviously
Mantra is the older one for Houdini and
yeah karma is the newer one for Houdini
mantras the OG the OG the slow G yeah I
call it a dude like ilm used it for a
lot of stuff yeah so it works yeah
another karma karma xpu experience which
is limited but faster well I saw a
glimpse into what's coming but you can't
say can you son of a gun son of a gun
tell us when it's over yeah when the
cameras are off yeah I'm sure all right
Christian the camera's off
that's entrapment
um okay well that's very exciting yeah
yeah I guess I I've said this a lot as
well but to anyone who out there who's
like intrigued by Houdini but but
intimidated by it
give a shot because again like I don't
have the brain for it
um and I fell in love with it and like I
guess it's my mission now like you would
nuke you open nuke up to me and I'm so
grateful for that because that has just
improved my Artistry a hundred times
over and same with Houdini like give it
a shot set aside some time and really go
for it Jordan just did a Click by click
it was an hour-long tutorial on
recordodigital.com website yeah there
you go yeah you can get a free
subscription and that's that's a really
fun little demystifying dive into one of
my projects in Houdini that you might
find valuable so you know check that out
and hopefully you get something from it
but I actually watched it oh you did I
did how was it it's pretty good hey all
right we'll take that from an
established Houdini artist I don't know
anything about kinefx so like you just
by showing the basics yeah and it was
fine it was Click by click yeah so I can
I'm like oh I can actually use this
tutorial yeah to do some skin effects
now yeah you can add that little
endorsement to the description
back in the studio if stuff if they did
something that was really good I said oh
it's fine yeah and that was my highest
compliment yeah so it's okay it's the
worst or it's fine yeah oh wow yeah so
I'm at the top of the yeah it's fine
that's awesome
um I guess yeah I I would have one last
question for you uh you know Houdini
artist for eight years explosion Centric
there are so many other tools in Houdini
what else interests you inside of
Houdini inside of Houdini yeah what else
interests you
I love doing magical stuff like just
magical effects like particles and
because the thing is with particles like
magical effects usually again it comes
back to compositing usually they look
very bad when you're rendering just
particles and then you go into
compositing you add some motion versus
light nice glows you had motion blurred
particles yeah after a render a lot of
times yeah yeah you can do it you can do
it really yeah yeah yeah why well
sometimes it's just faster but I mean if
you're talking particles we're talking
swirly magic right yeah we're talking
sub step curls I mean it depends on the
deadline yeah sometimes it's just faster
to do it in comp yeah you can do like
vector blurs yeah good old motion blur
node yeah I have never had success with
effects sometimes it's even better it
makes it more magical because it kind of
Blends yeah yeah yeah it gives it that
magical feel because yeah I mean the
thing with that would be like come
around your time in Houdini it would
know what particles what the IDS remain
consistent so it could follow the
particles but yeah once you render it
that's baked that's lost so I'm actually
surprised that works oh yeah I would
think that it would lose track of
everything works throw it out of focus
glow it yeah yeah that's it calm magic
maybe yeah oh man saving deadlines magic
stuff that's awesome yeah because also
with magic you can go back to anime like
anime yes they do magic or anything the
anime is the best like I always
reference anime for everything who did
the VFX for rock paper scissors me Jalen
Matt Nico Sam
like because they're 2D elements yeah a
lot of those are just from uh production
create footage crate oh yeah yeah okay
and then just a combination of different
things like uh some of them we took
actual like 2D elements and then ran
that through stable diffusion so it's
generating like an image sequence yeah
yeah that looks animated wow really cool
so cool so the timing was perfect ah
dude there was that was the thing like
from day one Nico was very much like we
have to nail the timing of everything
and it's like that's what gives it the
feel because I don't know we've been
going back and forth talking because
we're making a second one and it's like
okay
how do we
you know further make this feel anime
and so doing some explosion
wasn't Nico talking about trying that
like getting an explosion and then
throwing it through stable yeah that
would be a really cool that would be a
good test that's fun that would be a
good test yeah yeah yeah but even like
like Sam's comps for that yeah are are
completely the best shots in the whole
thing like his his understanding of
motion he actually put anime on his
secondary monitor yeah as he was working
that's something I always forget to do
is use reference like obviously use
reference yeah always yeah but the fact
that he's just playing shows I started
doing that too while I was working and
trying to inspire the Sam in me you know
yeah but yeah reference I'm glad you
liked it man like yeah I can't stress
enough how much Artistry is in it you
know it's it's not just a one button
click no it's great you know I loved it
I laughed a lot yeah it's so over the
top yeah yeah yeah yeah it really is
like with all the explosions and the
anime like it feels it feels legit yeah
thank you I love it that you guys got a
lot of praise for it as well like from
like traditional animators yeah like
that was cool yeah doing the doing the
react episode after yeah and getting
getting that kind of love there's the
first draft of the script anime
alert oh Christian's gonna have to edit
is that for the second one oh shoot wow
dang just the first step hold on but if
I give you this then you got to give me
that info can I see about what's coming
oh yeah
that's what we call I'll try that and
under the table deal ladies and
gentlemen wow uh well yeah with that
thank you for watching uh this is a
yeah yeah yeah
um what are your socials where can you
find you do you have a website I think
if you type Urban explosions guy you're
gonna find my LinkedIn my Twitter yeah
because that's like I'm branding it like
that yeah also by the way I'm doing I'm
gonna do a YouTube channel nice it's
gonna be called Urban explosions guy is
it really yeah yeah that's amazing what
I'll do is I'll just go
uh and just
compile the best reference pack of
explosions like from movies live action
whatever and I'll kind of react to them
like what do you guys do like it's a
super original idea
and I'll then try to recreate them like
you using Houdini like some of them not
all that's actually really even anime
I'll go through anime explosions and
I'll be like this is how you do an anime
explosion you know and then I'll try to
teach people how to do it using Axiom
and yeah doing yeah Education Plus
reacting to explosions I really want to
own like I'm planting my flag here ex
explosions guy nobody can touch that
so you'll have to make it before this
releases or else that's going to get
taken yeah yeah yeah yeah so I'll do a
YouTube channel so yeah dude I've been
pitching this I don't I think I talked
to Christian about it we need to do an
episode where we do what you got so Nico
would do a live action explosion and
then the two of us or all three of us we
would do a a CG exposure that'd be
awesome and we would compete because we
should do it the thing is I want to see
that as an audience member yeah but I
would love to do the explosions oh
that'd be so fun man you know and then
the audience would decide which one is
better because I feel I feel like if we
would
you know take the anime reference for an
explosion we would definitely win oh
shoot shots fired dude Nico might have
to team up with Adam Savage on that wow
this is practical would be pretty sweet
like the VFX uh action VFX guys like
they do really yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're awesome yeah they could do a few
explosions we could do like a good good
explosion okay that sounds really fun
yeah let's do it we'll talk to Nico
about that one yeah let us know in the
comments if you want to see that yes do
it yeah and also yeah check out Urban
online Urban brodesco he's a fantastic
educator and obviously very talented
artist himself so he's got a lot of cool
resource online for you to take a look
at yeah oh we also have like Theory
accelerated uh on YouTube it's just at
Theory accelerated uh I just released
like a full free workshop for uh Axiom
oh dude and I go through like how to do
like basic explosions how to do like
some photo real fire and stuff like that
so amazing that's awesome amazing well
thanks for joining us man really
appreciate it super fun and uh I'll see
on the next one
thank you